тільки тільки мене не
залишай сонцем небом
дощем снігом вітром бавагаю ще тільки
тільки мене не залишай
гей не
залишай
гей не залишай
гей не
залишай не
залишай сонцем небом
дощ снігом вітром благаю ще тільки
тільки мене не
[музика]
залишай ви побачите сьогодні дуже багато
славних людей вже бачили ви почуєте дуже
важливі речі але одне з найголовнішого
наша сила в єдності наша сила в
цінностях наша сила в наших дітях І в
наших батьках Ну і ще наша сила в тому
що Україна велика Може ви знаєте я з
Харкова і перші мої концерти були у
Львові а потім багато хто думав що я зі
Львова але є пісні які знають всі і які
співають всі заспіваю вам щось таке що
співала Моя бабуся Співаємо разом тому
що деколи Ми українці Від заходу до
сходу одна
душа
цвітитерен
[музика]
гей світе терен світе Терен а цвітопадає
хто з
любов'ю не не
знається той воря не
знає Хто з
любов'ю не
знається той горя не
[музика]
знає А я
молода дівчина тай воря
зазнала
вечероньки не
доїла нічки
[музика]
недоспала
вечеро онькім
недуїла нічки
недоспала ой візьму я крі
селечко сяду край
віконця і іще очі не
дримали а вже сходить
сонце
іщела очі не
тримали а вже сходи
[музика]
сонце ой Ріма йте не
трімайте не будете спати
рест поїхав мій
миленький
іншої
шукати десь поїхав мій
миленький
іншої
шукати Ну і давайте так разом
заспіваємо щоб до центру України до
Києва а там і до Харкова було
чути
світтерен
світтетерен
АІ
погає Хто з
любов'ю не
знається той горя не
знає Хто з
любов'ю не знає
той горя не
знає Хто з
любов'ю не
знається той горя не
[музика]
знає не може вашії увації Марія Бурмака
аплодисменти друзі ваші
Оплески дякуємо дякуємо ще ще ще
львівбрхливими ласми проважаємо дякуємо
друзі Ми продовжуємо концерт для
європейського міста та для справжніх
європейців тих людей які Я запрошую на
цю сцену зараз їхня творчість і зараз
надихає нас всіх на перемогу там де вона
найбільш необхідна у найгарячіших точках
боротьби за рідну землю Їхня сила у
поєднанні народної музики авторських
творів І що найважливіше чіткого
проукраїнського меседжу понад 1000
концертів в зоні та ос пісні які лунали
і на Майдані пісні які співають в цілому
світі добровольчий батальйон імені
Генерала Кульчицького під ваші борхливі
овації гурт кулі ваші
оплески
славасу 45 дорогий львію по-людськи Все
як має бути Я вчора зрано з Києва
приїхав он їхались Ми з
колегами тай заглядаю якась така звичка
дурнувата після вчорашньої поїздки на
Київ на небо се дивлю Поки вони се
включають Я два слова задивляюся на небо
бо бо там по Києву там один такий є в
нього телевізор вже не робить Каже
что-то у меня телевизор работает що
Бандера опять приехав що Майдан буде
кажу заспокіюся я приїхав до колегів тот
подивитися де слуги бо мені треба слуги
вже забрати з Верховної Ради нема кому
бульби копати рік тому послали з
мослугів туда а воно піш послали на
екскурсію Ні а воно сти слугу під стіл а
воно вилізло на стіл а бульбу докопати
треба кажу будем забирати помало слугиів
звітом та й дивлю та але ну 45 але і
дивлюся каже А да ты понимаешь что здесь
летают над Киевом а там на Дарниці жили
відьми давно а тут зелена парасоля і
летить і жовтий плащдай шляхтра я с
перепудив розумієте люди я туто не
розуміюся як мо і каж в тих інтернатах
летить жовтім плащі і на тому народ вони
нас мають що за лохів бо він каже Я не
лох А що я лох Що Іван лох Та Іван має
метр 90 хлопчику якби ті так вхопив він
80тку пройшов якби Т вхопив так за шийку
то би самон був як той когутик на
караківськім базарний а вон каже що ми
лохі і Нам показує як ту ту бабу мера
повісили на кран друзі біда крановщик
пішов в туалет і забрав з собою ключі
від крана два дни висіла Я вчора їхав з
вона ще висіла там негодні були з Отакі
цуда але це вони нас мають за за тих
лухів і таке покажуть по телевізору як
та дитина ірландська компанія
електрокомпанія показує оцей вітер ми
будемо використовувати і показує як
дівчинка типа Мері поппнс як летить з
парасолькою А ту
вирещучкуто я я я розумієте в мене сили
нема не маю я сили терпіти такки вже і
цей тут би ще гітара А є включена так і
та Рава Руська як всі забрала грали
руські хлопці музиканти по барах два дні
грали парнос не брали за дурно свето
було праздник пораворуский був каже
Тепер як вона летіла раворуська баби
стала на тому і дують аби сюда Не дай
Бог вітром не Занесло а київські
дівчонки звід там І куда десь не знаю
занесло на ту на бабу на родну мать Десь
там за шию зачепилося парасолю і Ліз
лізло по плеча хажтуло нижче і каже
зачепилася там за ту за гузи вродінімать
хто її там знімати буде ось така от
штука маємо і така політика і вони нас
думають знов дальше ну на ну тихні людей
що тут але є ж люди в яких зелний
телевізор тільки одним цветом показує і
ці люди знов будуть іти і рішати за нас
і воно хоче за мене рішати за тебе мій
рідний і Львів за нас хоче вирішити бо
їх каже їх больше
фіга вас больше нас буде більше і тому я
думаю що хтось зробив помилку ішов шов
пішов як той по гриби пішов тай де
ступив ного в стежку в бік але вийшов на
дорогу подивився бо дайго шлях де мене
занесв все більше туди не йду і все і
так Маємо зробити товариство маємо йти
вийти на дорогу до Європи тому я дякую
хто зорганізував он є хлопці і оркомітет
європейці і це все от дітям оцими
надовними кульками з європейською
солідарністю Чекай не пускайще і Дякую
що ми сьогодні є я вам дякую Львів Наша
перша пам'ять бо якщо людина пам'ятає
може йти на вибори Як нема пам'яті
телевізор зелений амбец гайка все вже
включили
все так і почнемо з нашої першої пам'яті
з тої з тих далеких Карпат там де хлопці
в роки назад вийшли не мали Я кажу
прапора над обласною радою над кийовом
над дрогобичами над стрійом над селом а
мали тут прапор і вийшли з Криївки і
пішли в бій тих хлопці маю маємо
пам'ятати завжди їх навчити оце
покоління їх привчити до того що це наш
прапор наша земля і нам ми не слуги нам
не треба наймитів нам треба господарю до
до влади і тоді ми щось будемо робити на
нашій землі Ми хочемо бути господарями
на своєму землі а не слугами дякую наша
починаємо з тої пам'яті цю пісню написав
пам'яті хлопців УПА з
Криївки
Дякую Дякую що ви в цю неділеньку світу
прийшли на цей Майдан прийшли до батька
порадитися послухатися я слухаю вас от
спілкуємося щось послухаємо нам люди
скажуть мудре і ми маємо
пам'ять пам'ятаємо Все я вітаю цей
прапор Білорусії теж пам'ятаємо
берестейщину пам'ятаємо пам'ятаємо все і
це що москаль нам диктує тепер Білорусія
вже сказала хватить
Бри терпеть не будем і мусимо їх також
підтримувати тому підтримуємо
їх сотнях УПА були
нації і Степан Бандера сказав Воля
людині Воля народум ми так Ідемо дальше
то є Європа так маємо бути і так буде цю
пісню так само я дописував першй куплет
десь на дебальце другий куплет дописував
ще ще я не пам'ятаю вуглегорськ Ізюм
Слов'янськ це куплет знаємо всі можемо
співати разом але куплети а приспіви Я
приспівзнаємо всі а куплету то я писав
ти по дорогах АТО і ця пісня стала от
будьте уважні друзі любимая песня
миномтчик альохи з Харкова я так вона
десь на концерті приїжджаємо він так
ззаду з гальоки ценик давай нашу любимую
ну зараз нашу для гальорочки там 80
хлопці вон стоять молодші
метал друзі такий при неділі святий
тяжкий метал маскальови поголої тяжким
металом хардрок від Мого діда ще цій
пісні 100 років але куплети написані
тепер ту славу дідову продідову маємо
нести дальше передати дітям і нехай
несуть дальше її славу про наших героїв
славу про нашу боротьбу про наші
Перемоги буде перемога я в це вірю
[музика]
Гай
лі Слава
Україні що нас почули далеко і звідси з
України і до Білорусі живі Білорусь
Слава Україні
гурт кулі ваші облески а кулям потрібен
порох Дякую вам хлопці друзі швиденько я
вже сюди для вашої уваги запрошую для
слова народний депутат України Андрій
парубі
зустрічаємо
Слава
українілава вітаємо в нас на Майдані
Петра Олексійовича Порошенка пятого
президента України
вітаємо сьогодні дуже символічно що
європейська Солідарність свій перший
візит напередодні місцевих виборів
робить власне у Львів адже тут уль
І тут на цій площі на цьому
майдані в кінці 80-х років минулого
століття виборювалась українська
незалежність тоді Львів і Львівщина дали
приклад усій Україні як відстоювати
Українську Державу і завдяки Львову
завдяки цьому Майдану Ми отримали
Львівську українську незалежну державу
тут ми піднімали вперше український
прапор тут ми вперше вико
український
гімн Я хочу нагадати що усі ініціативи і
Майдан помаранчевий і Майдан гідності
починали свої ініціативи звідси зі
Львова перед нами виступав Зеник Я хочу
йому особливе вітання з батальйону
Кульчицького який як символ львів'ян
заеник чуєш мене Ми тебе
вітаємо від 90х років Я згадую на
Майдані кожного світанку коли починався
новий ранок на Майдані Заник виходив
своїми піснями і піднімав бойовий дух і
коли прийшов час йти захищати Україну
від Московського агресора Заник і сотні
тисяч таких як він пішли добровольцями
на передову щоб захистити Україну і
особливо симвонічно було рік тому коли
вся країна на жаль вся наша держава
захворіла такою бацилою бацилою
популізму з іменем Зеленський коли по
всій
Україні через пропаганду олігархічних
каналів величезна кількість людей
голосувала за Зеленського і його команду
встояв тільки один регіон встояло тільки
одне обласне місто Це був Львів і
Львівщина я хочу подякувати усім вам за
це
бо я завжди говорив Львів - це фортеця
фортеця української державності і
сьогодні за півтора року після
президентських І за рік після
парламентських
виборів львів'яни знають що тоді рік
тому Львівщина була повністю права все
про що ми передбачали все про що ми
попереджа ле відбувається буквально з
перших місяців команда Зеленського
почала грати в одну гру з Путіном
проводячи нові формати так звані Мінські
Маючи на меті капітуляцію перед Путіном
перед Росією і тільки завдяки того тому
що ми всі разом і європейська
Солідарність тоді вийшли на майдани і в
Києві і у Львові і в інших містах Нам
вдалось зупинити капітуля
минулої
осені кілька тижнів тому в них нова
ініціатива
появилася щоб знищити закон про мову і
закон про освіту Ви пригадуєте ті дні як
всі ми вболівали щоб в Україні нарешті
був Український закон про українську
мову вони вирішили його знищити
напередодні 1
вересня ми тоді разом змогли об'єднатись
і європейська Солідарність і українці і
львів'яни і не допустили знищення закону
про мову і закону Про освіту і завдяки
нашим зусиллям зпер вересня 200 000
учнів в Україні почали своє навчання на
українській мові ті які ще вчилися до
минулого року на російській мові 200
молодих українців наших дітей будуть
мати право і можливість вчати українську
мову з першого класу своєю материною і
рідною мовою Протягом цього року ми
бачили що в них є один ворог не Путін і
навіть не Медведчук не Рабінович
згадайте скільки за цей рік було справ
проти медведчука або проти
рабіновича
жодної Зате проти президента України
Порошенка було відкрито 34 кримінальних
справи вони визначили собі одного ворога
Це український табір українська опозиція
і Петро Порошенко проти Порошенка проти
нашої команди Софії федини яка є тут з
нами Тетяни Чорновіл Володимира
вятковича відкриваються нові і нові
справи з метою щоб їх кинути
заграти Андрія парубія також кримінальні
справи Так п'ять кримінальних справ за
Майдан і за те що ми визволяли Одесу
проти мене від кримінальна справа і
проти десятків волонтерів наших бійців з
передової деякі з них і сьогодні
перебувають загратими Таке враження що
їхня головна ціль - це знищити весь
український табір і знищити європейську
Солідарність бо ми єдині хто чинимо їм
системний опір бо зараз напередодні
місцевих виборів Вони готують новий етап
капітуляції І ми його чуємо у виступах
Кравчука Фокіна яких призначили в
переговорну групу в Мінськ ви пам'ятаєте
Вони обіцяли нам нові обличчя от маєте
нові обличчя Кравчук і
Фокін
один комуніст і другий комуніст той
нафталін що ми думали що ми вже назавжди
їх забудемо що їх вже не буде на
політичній арені але заленських витягує
за вуха і вони нам сьогодні розповідають
про те що виявляється треба давати
автономію всьому Донецьку і всій
Луганській області А в мене питання до
них Поки ви робили свої
корпоративи Поки ви робили свої концерти
Ви знаєте скільки тисяч і десятків тисяч
українців загинуло за кожний метр за
кожний кілометр української землі в
Донецьку і в Луганську ви пам'ятаєте той
день коли головнокомандувач Петро
Порошенко дав наказ на український
Контрнаступ коли українські звільнили
2/3 українського Донбасу і Донеччини і
Луганщини сотні наших побратимів тисячі
наших побратимів і поестер загинули
звільняючи українську землю а вони
сьогодні проголошують що ці землі які
були звільнені мають стати маріонетковим
так званим днрлнр тобто віддати повністю
під контроль Росії Тому перед нами
стоять дуже важливі етапи боротьби І
тому ми
усвідомлюємо місцеві вибори - Це новий
етап боротьби за Україну Який є перед
нами усіма Це новий етап який має
продемонструвати що Українські сили
мають здатність і можливість
об'єднуватись перед загрозою яка
сьогодні не висла перед Україною тільки
нікчемні політики цього не розуміють які
знову ж таки визначають ворогом не
Путіна не рабіновича не медведчука а
Порошенка європейську Солідарність а усі
українські сили напередодні цих виборів
мають продемонструвати Єдність і стати
плече до плеча бо від кожного з нас
залежить майбутнє нашої держави бо такої
небезпеки як є сьогодні ми не бачили від
часів 14-го року коли російський агресор
пішов війною на Україну І тому я хочу
закликати усіх до єдності в ці тривожні
дні для України до об'єднання і до нової
мобілізації щоб Львів знов став
прикладом для всієї України Щоб
Львівщина була дороговказом для всієї
України бо Львів це фортеця і Я
переконаний з нами Бог і з нами буде
перемога Слава
Україні Слава Україні Героям слава слава
українігероям слава народний депутат
України паробі подякуємо друзі до
вітального слова Я запрошую народного
депутата України Миколу
княжицького Слава
Україні Слава львів'янам Дякую вам
приємно бачити вас моїх земляків тут в
своєму рідному місті з моєю сильною
найсильнішою в Україні командою на чолі
з Петром олексійовичем
Порошенком я невипадково згадав про
європейську Солідарність ми дійсно
говоримо напередодні місцевих виборів і
ви чудово Знаєте що зараз є три
політичні сили які ділять цей великий
електоральний пиріг який є лідерами яких
є найбільше симпатиків на жаль це
антиукраїнська опозиційна платформа
проросійська антиукраїнська гедотна
політична сила це їхні союзники зі слуг
народу і це ми найбільша українська
політична сила європейська Солідарність
відповідальність яка лежить на нас зараз
і на нас і на вас і на кожному з
мешканців нашого міста тому що ми всі
разом вона величезна наша
відповідальність перемогти всюди в
Україні на заході на сході розкажу вам
одну історію для нас справді дуже
важливо бути лідерами не лише тут у
Львові де ми є лідерами а й в східних
регіонах і Петро Олексійович попросив
мене допомогти нашим друзям з Полтавщини
у їхній роботі І як же я здивувався коли
буквально позавчора на сесії Полтавської
міськради під час голосування за
встановлення пам'ятника герою України
петлюрі лише одна фракція проголосувала
проти одна в полтавській міській раді і
ц фракція називається Самопоміч нашого
міського
і коли я дивлюся на те що
відбувається коли я бачу як знищується
українська традиція Я розумію що ми
справді в небезпеці небезпека надходить
з різних сторін Петро Олексійович був
тією людиною яка організувала підписання
безвізу завдяки чому кожен з нас міг
принаймні до карантину і зможе коли ми
його подолаємо попри всю безхребетність
зеленої влади їздити вільно до Європи
зараз європейські краї заявляють про те
що вони скасують безвіз Чому Тому що
антикорупційні органи до яких Так у нас
є багато претензій але які почали
працювати зараз знищуються цією зеленою
владою бажання все взяти під себе і не
34 справи порушити надуманих проти Петра
Олексійовича А ще якусь кількість проти
кожного патріота України софіяфдина в
них великий ворог українського народу
тепер вони хочуть і далі це продовжувати
а Європа каже якщо ви знищуєте те що
було створено за минулих пять років без
візу не буде ми не допустимо їм цього
зробити Захистимо європейський вибір Так
Так дякую Львову Захистимо не лише
європейський вибір Захистимо свободу
слова Ми бачили як на минулому тижні
абсолютно безпідставно вперше в Україні
прямий FМ було позбавлено шести ліцензій
радіо яке почало працювати яке говорило
українцям правду було вимкнене з ефіру
без жодних законних підстав А ніхто не
вимикає ті гедотні телеканали які Росію
пропагують А ніхто не вимикає телеканал
наш який крутить Вибачте ролик про те
якою трагічною була українська
незалежність як добре було в Радянському
Союзі і далі значить треба творити
голодомори Розстріляне Відродження
вбивати українців вони до цього ведуть
ви бачили на вулиці Білорусі танки це
п'ята колона яка хоче щоб танки були на
вулицях Львова але ми європейська
Солідарність не допустимо цього не
допустимо бо ми сильні єдині Ми
переможемо у Львові Ми почнемо нашу
переможну ходу зі Львова для того щоб
завершити її в Харкові а далі перемогти
ворога і на його території
Так дякую
вам Львів - це місто си
кожен з вас це в кожному з вас сила
українського народу Дякую Слава
Україні народний депутат Микола
Княжицький друзі а зараз на цій площі
для вас пролунає наш гін перед тим ми
почуємо слова лідерів європейської
солідарності для вас українські народи
для вас цей гімн гімн збройних сил
України зродились ми великої
зробились ми великої години звожеж війни
і полумя вогнів плекав нас біль за долю
України зростив нас Гнів ідуть на
ворогів лекав нас біль зато волю України
зростив нас Гнів і людь на ворогів
[музика]
ми йдемо в бій переможним ходом твердій
від сніг не злам німов краніт бо блач не
дав нікому ще Свободи хто борець той
здобува є світ бо влащу не дав нікому ще
Свободи хто борець той знову має
світ Україно Україно сятавати герою
сятавати герою ди до Сея мого зійди до
серцея мого за твою славу за твою славу
за твої святі ідей за твої святі ідеї
нехай душа моя в тобі відродиться нехай
душ тобі в Слава Україні
Слава Слава на
Україна понад усе Україна понад
усе велику суть для усіх єдину наш
гордий Клич народові несе вітчизні буть
тий вірний без зупину нам
Україна вище понад все
відчистьні хть Ти вірний вер зупину на
бу країна вище понад
[музика]
всеце на
браття
українці
усміхнеться
доля
Згинуть наші
боріженьки як роса на
сонці
запанує міїми браття у свої
стороннці душ іло ми
положим за нашу
свободу І
покажем що ми браття
коцаського
роду Слава
Україні
Слава Отже друзі
зустрічаємо ми високоповажних гостей
сьогодні у Львові п'ятий президент
України Петро Порошенко і його дружина
Марина народний депутат України Олег
Синютка з дружиною
[оплески]
Наталею до слова запрошую народни
депутат України Олег
Синютка
дорогі
львів'яни Шановний пане
президенте пані
Марино чому ми сьогодні
тут напевне кожен скаже я прийшов тому
що сьогодні тут мій Український
президент лідер європейської
солідарності Петро Порошенко Так це
правда
[оплески]
А ще напевне кожен собі задасть
запитання що я прийшов сьогодні сюди
тому що завтра будуть місцеві вибори від
яких Багато залежить з яких повинно
початися не тільки кінець зеленої влади
з яких повинно початись відродження
України Так
так але ще багато хто сьогодні з нас
прийшов тут тому що ми точно знаємо що
сьогодні тут у центрі Львова є ще
багато-багато тисяч українців які
знаходяться за 1000 кметрів від нашого
Шевченка від нашої площі це українські
воїни які захищають нас які захищають
нашу державу які захищають нашу свободу
І на
жаль
21 з них вихідець з Львівщини поклав
своє життя за те щоби ми мали можливість
будувати і відроджувати Україну і
сьогодні Львівщина
прощається з 321 героєм вихідцем з
дрогобичини Тарасом
кравшичаком я прошу його пам'ять його
честь його славу і пам'ять всіх тих
українців хто поклав своє життя за нашу
свободу і незалежність вшанувати
хвилиною
[музика]
мовчання
А ще ми зібралися
тут Тому що ми точно знаємо що від
Революції гідності і до сьогоднішнього
опору капітуляції ми недаремно прожили
цих сть років тому що що Вони думають що
Для нас це були передвиборчі гасла А ми
точно знаємо що це сутність нашої
України це сутність тої України за яку
ми воюємо за яку ми стоїмо і з якою ми
обов'язково переможемо і сутність нашої
України ввійшла в три простих слова але
це три слова які чітко ставлять
водорозділ і ставлять від відповідь на
питання хто Ти українець чи ти Зайда і
ці слова прості але відомі і зрозумілі
кожному це слова армія мова Віра армія
мова Віра армія мова Віра армія мова
Віра і ми знаємо і ми знаємо що ці слова
як і багато інших речей це є заслуга
людини яка сьогодні є разом з нами
людина яка півтора року уже очолює
український Спецназ в парламенті людина
яка багато що зробила для того щоби
Україна ставала українською щоби гімн
нової української армії Звучав голосно
на всю країну щоби українці відчували
себе заможнішими в нашому складному
житті щоби Україна була сильною і міцною
і її поважали на міжнародній арені
Давайте скажемо просте українське слово
дякую дякую пане президенте
дякуємо
дякуємо дорогі
львів'яни європейська
Солідарність піде на місцеві вибори
європейська Солідарність - це потужна
сила це потужна українська партія яка
тут у нас на Львівщині запропонує для
людей своїх кандидатів в кожну об'єднану
територіальну громаду в кожен район на
львівську обласну Раду і коли мене
питають Чому ти говориш що без Львова
нема України а я їм кажу без Львова нема
України тому що європейська Солідарність
- це не просто українська партія це
партія львів'ян це партія українців це
наша партія з якою ми разом підемо до
перемоги Ми повинні перемогти Ми підемо
на місцеві вибори і європейська
Солідарність переможе на місцевих
[оплески]
виборах
тут серед тисяч
львів'ян
разом з п'ятим президентом України
Петром Порошенком з моїми колегами по
українському
парламенту Я хочу перед вами сьогодні
сказати
я Олег Синютка прийняв
рішення я буду балотуватися на посаду
Львівського Міського голови від
європейської солідарності
[оплески]
Я тут стою перед
вами
молодець
мололоделоде Я тут стою перед
вами і я прошу двох
речей
я
прошу вашої
підтримки я прошу вашої довіри і Повірте
я не
[оплески]
підведулодець
молодець
молодецьло І
коли І коли нас сьогодні питають а З чим
ви підете вибори Як ви переконаєте
львів'ян щоби вони зрозуміли що
європейська Солідарність - це та
політична сила з якою Львів зміниться це
та політична сила яка допоможе
львів'янам відчувати себе комфортним в
своєму місті при якій точно Ніхто з
львів'ян не буде мріяти їхати кудись в
Європу бо ми знаємо що Європа буде в
Україні то я вам скажу що що моя візія є
дуже проста і вона повинна бути
зрозуміла для кожного львів'янам має
бути жити комфортно у Львові і ми
зробимо для львів'ян комфортне життя у
[оплески]
Львові але Коли мене запитають Яка місія
Львова то я вам скажу ще
простіше колись полковник Євген
коновалич сказав що шлях до Львова
лежить через Київ а я більше цього скажу
Львів має бути поважним у Східній Європі
Львів має бути партнером Праги Львів має
бути партнером бухареста Відня Варшави і
всіх тих столиць де люди живуть Добре Де
комфортно де Свобода де незалежність і
де люди поважають один одного де люди
пишаються тим що вони живуть в такому
славетному
місті і я скажу вам дуже
просто почуйте і
Повірте Настав час Львова Настав час
перемагати Львову і Львів
переможе тому
що моя програма є дуже проста по-перше
Львів знову стане центром науки освіти
тому що львів'ян це ті хто записали своє
ім'я На скрижалях наукових досліджень і
Я переконаний що молоді люди студенти
школярі вчені вони зрозуміють Що тут у
Львові можна не тільки отримати
високоякісну освіту яка дасть добру
зарплату Що тут у Львові Можна
реалізувати свій потенціал стати
впізнаваним у світі закарбувати своє
ім'я серед багатьох і багатьох наукових
товариств і ми згадаємо науко товариство
Шевченка І ми піднімемо статус наукового
товариства Шевченка І кожен львів'янин
буде гордитися якщо його ім'я буде
пов'язано з наукою і освітою але
по-друге Львів точно стане центром
технологій Так ми дуже серйозно
просунулися в галузі it але Я
переконаний що ми повинні відродити
економічну силу Львова що змінилося з
того часу коли Львів був учасником
космічних програм що змінилося з того
часу коли Львів забезпечував виробництво
військово-промислового комплексу коли
Львів славився на всю Європу своєю
продукцією змінилося тільки одне
недолуга влада яка не розуміє що наша
сила в нашій економіці наша сила в наших
людях і ми піднімемо виробництво у
Львові і вироблено у Львові вироблено в
Україні це буде знаком якості для всієї
Європи для всього
світу
по-третє ми гордимося
ми гордимося тим що дуже багато людей
приїжджають до Львова і ми кажемо що
туризм - це одна із візитівок Львова але
скажіть будь ласка нам потрібні голі і
босі туристи які часто приїжджають сюди
за сексуальними послугами Ні нам
потрібен інший туризм Нам потрібен
туризм який приїде сюди проводити
наукові конференції Нам потрібен туризм
який привезе сюди багатих людей з Японії
з Америки зі всіх країн світу Нам
потрібен зовсім інший статус в галузі
туризму щоб кожен сказав Якщо ти не був
у Львові значить ти не бачив Європи
такий туризм буде у
[оплески]
Львові
ми пишаємо тим що Львів беззаперечно є
культурною столицею але по-четверте
Львів повинен стати культурною столицею
українства досить хизуватися тільки
пампухами вльвівські пампухи фантастичні
Але нам треба продукувати зовсім інші
цінності це наша історія це наша
архітектура Ми повинні експортувати свої
звичаї Ми повинні експортувати свою ль
культуру Ми повинні експортувати свою
творчість Львів на світовій карті
культури повинен стати частиною не
Московського а панєвропейського
пансвітового простору тому що Львів був
і буде культурною столицею Європи і це
наш статус і так
буде і п'яте але напевно
найголовніше що вартує Львів без
львів'ян
скільки часу львів'яни ще будуть Тратити
свій час в оцих ненависних корках
скільки часу львів'яни ще будуть
записуватися в чергу в дитячі садочки і
в школи скільки часу Львівські
підприємці ще будуть носити хабарі
чиновникам тому п'яте але насправді
перше і основне Львів повинен бути
комфортним для львів'ян Львів буде
комфортним для життя львів'ян тому що
будуть будуватись підземні паркінги
будуть будуватись нові дороги будуть
нові садки нові школи будуть будуватись
не забігайловки А будуть будуватись
худочні і музичні школи Львів буде
містом де хочеться жити Львів буде
містом де хочеться творити Львів буде
містом Де кожен львів'янин не тільки з
гордістю скаже я зі Львова а з гордістю
скаже найкраще жити сьогодні завтра у
Львові тому Львів буде комфортним для
[оплески]
львів'ян
молодець
молодецьло Ми стоїмо тут на цій
площі чому Львів є тому що Господь Бог
колись своїм перстом вказав що тут буде
велике місто Великої держави великих
людей а наш король Данило реалізував
його волю і наші пращури наші предки
крок за кроком будували це місто ми є
нащадками гідної великої української
історії нам є чим пишатися нам є кого
шанувати нам єдине що заважає - це влада
яка повинна перестати брехати і красти і
ця влада повинна піти і відповісти за
все що вона створила з
Львовом Я
переконаний що від сьогодні ми
об'єднаємо свої зусилля ми станемо плече
до плеча ми станемо Серце до серця і ми
єдиними вустами єдиним голосом скажемо
на весь світ Настав час Львова Настав
час України настав часть Львова нача
Львова Ми підемо і переможемо бо Настав
час Львова Слава
україніла народний депутат України і від
сьогодні ві сам щойно сказав кандидат в
мери нашого європейського міста Львова
Олег
[оплески]
Синютка друзі з гордію запрошую до слова
саме з цієї площі поруч з Кобзарем
людину яку ми всі любимо і поважаємо
п'ятий президент України Петро
[оплески]
Порошенко дорогий мій
[музика]
Львів улюблені мої
львів'яни я тут для того щоби в першу
чергу подякувати
вас дякувати за те що ви є небайдужими
ще вчора Всі казали що з третьої по
шосту буде Злива буде
гроза лякали Не приходьте але тисячі і
тисячі львів'ян зібралися тут під ясним
сонечком і це означає що Господь з нами
на цю урочисту
церемонію визначення кандидата від
львів'ян і кандидата від європейської
солідарності на високу посаду
Львівського Міського
Голови я тут для того щоби подякувати
кожному з вас за потужну
підтримку яку я і моя команда відчували
кожного дня протягом останніх пти років
пяти років мого президентства можливо
найбільш важких часів в історії України
коли стояло питання
існування нашої держави і
відсічі російському
агресору Я дякую за те що Львів і
львів'яни були в перших рядах на чолі з
80ю бригадою яка і зараз пішла на бойове
злагодження для висунення в район
операції об'єднаних
сил Дякую за тобі за це Львів і дякую
тобі за це дорогі
львів'яни
Я дякую за потужну підтримку всього
комплексу реформ які були пов'язані з
угодою про асоціацію з Європейським
Союзом і дякую за те що в листопаді
грудні 13го коли почалася революція
гідності львів'яни на українському
Майдані були серед перших і тут так
Софія чи ні тут біля Шевченка був наш
Львівський Майдан який сказав рішучи ніз
спробам відтягнути Україну від
європейського вектору розвитку Дякую вам
за вашу
небайдужість я дякую
Львову за
ці півтора роки дуже
непростих дуже складних в історії
України хоча можу сказати чесно вам було
легше Бо вся решта
України спочатку зачарувалися в зелених
бездерях в зелених
[оплески]
неробах А вам було легше бо ви з самого
початку знали хто вони такі і на виборах
19го року ви чітко сказали рішуче ні так
званим зеленим слугам і дякую за це тобі
дорогий мій Львів і улюблені мої
львів'яни і коли за ці півтора років
стала загроза
капітуляції для того щоби висловити
протест під час акцій руху опору
капітуляції в грудні перед самітом
Нормандії хто пер
сказав рішучи ні капітуляції на користь
Росії Львів і львів'яни Дякую тобі за це
[оплески]
Львів і коли по
почалися брутальна економічна криза
Уявіть собі ми 5ть років піднімали
економіку
України наприкінці моєї каденції темпи
економічного зростання склада дали
4,5% державному казначействі було більше
млрдв на золотовалютних рахунках
золотовалютних резервах в
доларах що
трапилось чому ще задовго до
коронавіруса із-за абсолютної
некомпетентності влади так званих нових
облич де нове обличчя виявилися
так званих старків розбійників Фокіна і
Кравчука ми перейшли до крутого
економічного
Піке Україна
перейшла до руйнації
міжнародної коаліції на підтримку
України і українського суверенітету який
був створений нашою
командою Україна перейшла до ослаблення
армії яку ми з вами
збудували за 5 років і які на
сьогоднішній день є найбільш
авторитетною державною
інституцією Ви сьогодні в перших рядах
захисників армії бо армія
волонтери добровольці потребують вашого
захисту вже від так званої української
влади і ще одна дуже важлива річ
скажіть мені А хто висловлюючи позицію
львів'ян має казати в очі правду Зеленій
владі Я вважаю що міська
Влада щось я дуже не чув
рішучої позиції міської влади
навпаки поточна міська Влада займається
підлабузничеством і намагається
притягнути до себе увагу і захист
некомпетентної зеленої влади з Києва Так
кого ця Влада
представляє На мою думку точно не
львів'ян Бо коли навіть з Дніпра голос
міського голови Бориса Філатова Ми чуємо
коли він каже
правду
подіям діючої зеленої
влади Львівській владі як
пороблено
і я Хочу
наголосити всі ці мої твердження
наголошують
що Львівська влада і вибори міського
голови
це абсолютно аж ніяк не місцеві вибори
як це вам Може здатися
спочатку бо саме Від позиції
Львова залежить
цілісність України і історія це доводить
неодноразово бо саме Від позиції
львів'ян залежить відсіч
федералізації і це наводить
історія і багато інших речей реформ і
розвитку України починаючи з реформи
децентралізації яка була запропонована і
реалізована мною і моєю
командою коли міська Влада перетворилася
з каз виплати заробітної платні в
реальні фінансові по вирішення проблем
громади на сьогоднішній день і ця
реформа
згортається як вже казав Андрій
Парубій і українська мова і наші закони
про розвиток і захист української мови і
освіти
потребують вашої позиції дорогі
львів'яни
щоб Львів не мовчав і міська Влада не
мовчала а отже
а
отже місцеві вибори у Львівській області
і міські вибори у Львові
Це не про
каналізацію точніше не тільки про
каналізацію Це не про ліфти точніше не
тільки про
ліфти не
про поточний ремонт дорог і вуличне
освітлення точніше не тільки про це і
навіть Нехай Бог простить
не про
сміття
точніше не тільки про
сміття міські вибори у Львові і місцеві
вибори на Львівщині
це про
Україну Це про її
волю
це про її народ про її честь і про її
славу і тому лідером Львова має
бути загальнонаціональний
лідер який представляє
загальнонаціональну політичну
силу єдину Українську політичну силу
дорогі
львів'яни Підкажіть мені прізвища цього
лідера який має бути висунутий міським
головою
Львова не
чую
Отже Олег Михайлович
дорогий ти не тільки сам висунувся на
цьому мітингу ми тільки європейська
Солідарність тебе висунула і Для нас це
велика честь я прошу завжди пам'ятати що
тисячі львів'ян на цьому Майдані сказали
що їх міським головою має бути Олег
снютка ваш Оплески
сика
Синюка
сию Дуже дякую і головне
25го
жовтня 25 жовтня треба загітувати
всіх треба привести всіх явка має бути
рекордною бо як сказали мої побратими
ворогом для них є не
Путін ворогом для них є не Опа
зж ворогом для них
є Петро Порошенко європейська
Солідарність Олег сінютка і львів'яни
Отже хіба можуть вони нас перемогти
точно ні і 25 жовтня ми
маємо забезпечити перемогу України
перемогу українського народу перемога
львів'ян і лева міста і перемога Олега
сінютки і ваша реакція дає мені тверде
переконання що саме так і буде Тим
більше що вчора прийшла ще одна дуже
важлива звістка
Знаєте
яка
президент Російської Федерації
Путін Поки що
ні
уряд Російської Федерації країни
агресора своїм рішенням запровадив
жорсткі
санкції проти Петра
Порошенка проти Олега сінютки
проти того кого боїться президент
Зеленський Софії
федини проти Степана
кубіва проти Андрія лопушанського кого
ще
забув проти Михайла забродського героя
України
проти народного
депутата від партії європейська
Солідарність командира батальйону
госпітальєри Яни
Зінкевич проти члена європейської
солідарності народного депутата від
нашої фракції
рішучого антикомуніста Володимира
вятровича і проти
рішучого
політв'язня героя кримського татарина
справжнього українця ахтема чи го
за і великої кількості справжніх
патріотів
України хочу сказати щоб ви не
розстраювались за решти членів нашої
фракції проти них санкції були
запроторені Росією трохи раніше Отже це
як знак якості це як державна нагорода
України за відсіч російському
агресору
[оплески]
Отже Олег Михайлович Я вітаю вас всім
почесним
званням людини яка знаходиться під
санкціями До речі я під скажіть мені
діюча Влада Львова вона проти неї є
санкції Я думаю що не випадково дорогі
друзі насправді нам з вами треба
об'єднуватись нам з вами треба боронити
державу
нам з вами треба на Львові показати
приклад приклад для Харкова Запоріжжя
Дніпра Донецька Луганська Одеси
Миколаєва
Херсона
Полтави кропівницького Черкас
Чернігова Ну і врешті-решт приклад для
Києва бо як сказав Олег і я з ним
повністю згоден
час Львова настав давайте їм це покажемо
Дякую
Вам слава Львову і слава
Україні друзі ваші уваші пятий президент
України Петро
[оплески]
Порошенко вітаємо шановних гостей ще раз
у Львові родина
Порошенко Петро Порошенко тажи Марина ну
і звісно
майбутній майбутній мер Львова кандидат
на посаду Мери Львова Олег Синютка та
дружина
Наталя І звісно згідно нашої Української
європейської традиції адже ми
європейське місто і саме звідси повинна
розпочинатися Європа велике вічя велике
зібрання яке розпочинається так і
повинно завершитися нашим славним гімном
до виконання запрошую октет Орфей
Ще не
вмерла у
України ні
слава ні Боля
ще на
браття
[музика]
українці
усміхнеться
доля
звідуть
наші
вороженькі як
роса на
соннці
за
панує і ми
браття у
свої
стороі
Душу й
тіло ми
положим за
нашу
свободуду
і
покажем що ми
браття
козатського
роду
Душу й
тіло ми
положим за
нашу
свободуду
і
покажем що ми
браття
козацького
[музика]
Слава Україні Героям слава Слава Україні
Героям слава Слава Україні рідне Львове
Героям слава Дякую вам шановне панство
друзі з вірою в Україну з Україною в
серце і з Європою на нашому в нашому
розумі йдемо у світле майбутнє Дякуємо
висопредставленим нашим гостям Дякую
тобі рідний європейський
[музика]
Львове
[оплески]
[музика]